ah first world I'm green oh but can you
guys okay oh my god
holy Frick it works what is this Wow
oh my actual [ __ ] I can't believe this
is happening
that's crazy holy getting goosebumps
right now this is freaking out it's
really no this is a fast this is
fascinating this is really cool how do I
change my mouth how'd you guys change
your mind you affable man's voice like
voices the changing of the mouse
oh snap oh that's me oh yes this is not
me I don't know what is that is so you
or or you're the one with the beard I'm
green boy green boy I'm yellow if red
was an option why aren't you read
Markham to say this all right okay good
well I'm the blue oh I want to do that
yeah oh yeah mine likes out every now
and then not number one I'm number one
I'm number one
okay grab the platform I knew right we
got one of us is slow but you know we
just not tired
I didn't mean to hold your hand like
that you guys just decided to go to
you gotta let go all right get in there
thank you it was the beard it was like
oh that's a new state record that is a
new say because of rage
what oh hey oh hey give me your hand
Oh God armpits I don't okay so I let go
of left okay grab you got a grab I am
grabbing but it was too hard here we go
ready yep yep oh oh jeez yeah you can't
speak to her okay tapping stop tabbing
yep got it okay always all right all
right now let it settle let it settle
can we just give a real quick shout out
preach to steam real quick don't this is
cool I'm still literally like buzzing on
life right now I think it's not gonna
let go don't let go of me and I won't
let go of you I will not let go Bob your
whole job is to just stick us together
not right now holding me how did somehow
it's both of your right hands that's so
confusing it's fine yeah
like guys if there's a need for this
game I think we should be in it okay we
need to we need to pause for a second
and explain to the people watching why
this is so amazing okay that's a fair
point actually you give good
explanations so you explain okay well I
don't know man listen steam what you've
done is nothing short of a dime not even
grabbing anything you're fine okay so
the way the reason this is blowing our
minds or my mind at least is because
this game is local co-op only audience
sorry is not online is not online
multi-player capable the game itself has
no features that are allowing this to
happen but there's some sort of wizardry
out here we go the steam has made it
happen where that we're basically I'm
playing the game and jacquard mark are
watching a stream of my game yeah and
also controlling my game through their
Steam client which I don't even
understand how that's possible it's
really impressive don't actually
understand I'm coming but don't worry
I'm cool yeah oh that's the wrong one
hang on hang on Hannah makes there we go
ha ha I got you right by your right by
your grundle but anyway it's basically
actual magic and it's unbelievable ok ok
I'm in the middle we'll get once more
you wanna hang on yeah oh my card with
my left you just don't let go if your
left ok ok ok give me the coin yeah it's
perfect
ok mark you're gonna have to let go
we're gonna have to eat her
[Applause]
Oh way too early there all right okay
you go oh you're holding me by the okay
cross oh you're in the middle now Oh
grab it grab it grab it
oh gods use your left use your left and
grab the coin I believe in you oh we got
this swing him gently all right so not
now okay we're gonna swing down and then
I'll like on the upswing release all
right swing me back up there we're so
close we're so let's get in the thingy I
don't get off of me a lot of trusted me
this is a little like thing for a mark
it gives them like a cheater oh we oh
please don't include me in this out
there I don't want any part way we could
catch him hang on I could come help with
that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's mark
pull the handle there's a little this
time one of these things that'll come
back from the land on him land land on
him okay works alright well let me pull
this handle for you okay mark if you
could that's my face join you and you
left me okay oh oh he's farting does
that grab a grab him I'm a rounded one
of these two building me okay there we
go
Oh mark you're blocking him from these
fines fine fine it's dying a force or
whatever the hell's happening we're not
dying it's not good okay okay everyone
just take yours to take a sweet take
take a breath all right okay look I got
the coin you want to there we go okay I
don't know if you're actually grabbing
me okay you are okay there's a
sequencing issue happening drop grab my
take my okay oh well it's the thing why
are we all down here get the thing there
we go
okay boy that this working with with as
little lag as it is it's fine try and
grab
very casually so casually oh geez
anything else it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think hey Jack I think you should grab
the coin with your left hand I think you
should let go of your left hand and let
mark hold you yeah and then you try and
snatch the coin okay a little okay
perfect
all right which way do we want swing
this way okay pop I have I'll be middle
boy all right so my right my right arm
and my left arm are available for coin
purposes we'll just see how it works
your left arm okay this is a free hand
see this this is free all right you guys
are just a orgy of disaster you like
this is easy okay here we go you got it
you got it I believe in you okay oh yes
we can just we can just casually this to
myself hang on I got this I got this one
right hand and I'm gonna hang on this is
gonna work that would that work just
gonna totally work Oh grab a new one
yeah all right let me see if I grab it
with my can we get any lower
yeah can you literally let go for a
split second okay okay things are
happening okay and I'll let go your left
hand there baton okay okay if we if we
go
ray okay you should be in the middle in
there we go Oh perfect okay yeah there
we go okay we can yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah this is how we
oh okay my right hand is the freer get
that we're gonna get that we're gonna
[Applause]
mark used to be an engineer figure it
out I will how is this engineering at
all pretty aggressive oh that's not the
right one there we go okay I'm
constantly holding right I let go of the
wrong one now Smyly my oh okay I have
this okay we should be able to grab it
we should be able to grab it from here I
got it yeah Milo my right hand is free
let me get let me get that let me snag
let me hope that's not what you oh god
oh god okay okay
got it here we go all right here we go
okay just try grab it okay I'm letting
go oh and then bring it around whoa
[Music]
this game is so optimistic everything
you do it's just like new record boys do
what does this do I don't know are we
just angry at each other I know how to
fix this guys don't okay oh my god all
right now we just need to get full not
too fast swing but not too fast all
right do we want to try and get okay I'm
gonna let go of my right Bob you don't
let go of your left my right it's my
right my right
oh he's letting go of my left okay I'll
let mark do this he doesn't have enough
momentum to get you there bud to you
maybe
okay no all right I'm really gonna need
this hand though so we're gonna have to
oh that was close I think we toss it
into the end oh yeah can we just toss it
over there oh good let's say like this
let's stay like this let me just see if
I can mark you're holding the thing and
not me
so I can't read you like oh my right no
way okay now we're free again you're
grabbing the block all right sorry oh
okay wait maybe I can get into marks
right hand hang on let's bring it around
here oh and see if I can get it see if I
get into your right hand shoes right now
I'm gonna go can you yeah I'm gonna grab
like the top or something and so we can
we can stretch to the next Oh
all right there there I got it okay now
what now you
oh yes alright and then I'm good ok if
you maybe grab the bottom and just so we
don't have to do a dangerous reposition
that'd be nice you up a little bit there
you go perfect perfect for her I'm gonna
let go all right okay I can try and drop
a tiny tiny bit OOP oh what a pro I
think we're still short because my bow
position you're like oh also I'm still
absolutely marveling that any of this is
even happening I need you losers just go
a friend bring me with you no wait me
down
Bob we'd see to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
fine fine fine but I'm not happy about
it
coin is there coin yeah I like money
okay I would oh I would like some money
who doesn't I love money
Marty that's basically how I feel about
it
hey there's a coin there it is oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry
oh don't worry when I've got us here I
got the coin take my coin dance this way
let's be friends friends sorry yeah we
can grab some Oh God
okay are we back er okay I've got now
hang on Bob you let go of left okay okay
you let go
I got a guy okay who I'm really glad
that I brought us all together guys I
just want could've made it on my own
okay oh yeah he had to grab I got I did
this I did all of this I would like all
the credit please thank you very much
but next time you could let my for my
own hey what are you trying to do come
on your own you know my own oh I think
you know what we have to do now oh sweet
lord
oh no wait wait a minute wait wait wait
guys inside of each other I'm glad I'm
not holding on anything and me neither I
can't get off me I can't quit you
oh just like murder
terror God throw you the coin Bob
whatever Mac all right Bob I'm coming to
get the coin you cut if you come back
over here Marco I'm here here take that
guys what you want to do the coin yeah
I'll do the coin I love I love money
all right let's do this boy right this
is what we are here for the whole time I
did it on my own
yep it's whatever friends they
disappoint me whatever you say this
little project who put in note work but
go all the credit anyway all right now
you need my help I got no no we're fine
we're good we're good we're gonna get in
there me and get in there you get in
there all right okay fine
you green friend yeah you greens freak
who tried to do it on his own before
anybody sucked I'm in it I was the best
oh that's true you did really try and do
it on your own and you really screwed it
up you see Bob the key or the coin
also [ __ ] it up on purpose
sweet life holding on for dear life okay
hang on don't let go all right now we're
[Music]
gonna my god first try world record
absolute new record there that was an
adventure I don't know how we did oh no
the spikes oh god I don't let you move I
can
[Laughter]
okay okay okay you gotta let go whatever
you're touching over no mark has to come
up when I go now let's not do yeah I'm
not gonna let you swing I'm not gonna do
not let you swing with you will not sing
Chile the one close this is Mike and
you're gonna grab the wall with your
right hand with your right hand okay
okay okay you see the move got the pole
here bud I can I can get to you we don't
need your pity game you guys suck pull
this rope like lock your grip is that a
thing maybe probably enough like toggle
right try pressing a press anything
right now just press all the buttons
there are letters there a release all
grass yeah its alt rf-4c screw it hey
that's my Joey if I grab your head it
might be better yeah you're right you're
right okay am i yellow let go yes
I don't think that's good hold you up
hold you up okay okay okay this is
terrible wait I've said I think I have
to get around focused I'm gonna let go
and never mind
wait I think I should keep this hand
position yeah and I think Jack should
come around and take your left hand and
then see if we can like scooch me
through here very interesting very
smoothly Oh God you're really you're
really all over yourself I think I think
somebody has to get through first
without the others and then they have to
come back and get a strike I want I
think I got this you you take marks left
hand hold I'm gonna grab your your okay
we argue okay okay all right now if the
wall I've got you hit the wall I got
your wall oh nice thing interesting
interesting interesting very okay if I
hold you up I will hold you up okay okay
it's all right all right all right let
me grab all right okay lifting up do not
drop a little hard okay okay okay okay
position let me raise my hands
wanna see if we can just get through
here just the two all right I got it I
got it
this is insane straggler what we passed
our marks north never gonna dine the bad
way we need we need to get tons first
could have made through you both drop
that wouldn't be the most badass move in
history don't get listen everyone wanted
mark I feel like that was left behind
I'm saying I did it look how good you
are
Lodi was I don't want to hear oh I'm
sure he's got this no problem
done no you guys Wow good teamwork
everybody excellent teamwork I think
angst a you know I'm gonna give you
props for that one well actually you got
through the easiest
thank you all right every man for
himself grab the [ __ ] hand dude
alright there you go there you go
okay whatever okay let's be less energy
this which way we have left left Reese
let's go right what you dick well
where's the coin here we might be off to
the right to the right to the right nope
never mind no this is okay that was
interesting I think you can just do it
on your own yeah we could probably you
guys mightier sure you can't just do it
on your own I think you're right my left
good technique interesting interesting
interesting okay okay okay
very interesting
good technique that's a good technique
got something oh you have to
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like a good thing right you know let's
do the rope this time and see what it
does
this is the sweatiest my hands have ever
been high
alright Ravi okay there we go hello I'm
just gonna let go of the blueberry
I'm adorbs we need to we need to
reconfigure this game is I love these
tights wow that really sorted it out
okay cool I think it would be really
funny if there was an autoscroller level
oh god I'm pushing I am the hole okay
what's the game where you make a man
pile oh yeah I'm out your friends that's
what this is like it's a classic oh
don't shoot that one yet all right here
we go
what you doing there bud listen listen
listen
okay well if you're mine I did it then
you made me change it okay okay this is
what hell looks like oh no Jill we're
gonna just have to so she'll show it up
now oh it's clenched Oh French that's
not what you want to see for the horse
there jackaboy all right here we go man
who wants to go down the long skinny
hole like Bob you're gonna grab it for
us I think I may be maybe I've got a
hand maybe that left hand mark yeah okay
when you do a little bit no we need to
inchworm it mark you need to grab with
your right and then Jack you need to
raise your left we got to get it into
okay you're right you're right you're
right lift lift up back direct and then
scooch lift lift lift lift this is the
most efficient way to do this I'm one of
them
this is such an epic gamer moment that's
slowly up there alright this is sensual
is what this is this is a very say I'm
so proud of you guys
okay you got it you go that might be a
little premature we are okay four point
oh eight seconds away from a hilarious
joke I have never been more tense
playing a [ __ ] video game of my life
I might pass out and become French had
my actual weight be does something as
well oh I can make myself angry what
even is this thing we have to catch the
rope to the rope okay okay I have you
ready grab the coin bring back I'm try
okay okay yep oh dude perfect
we are the was I saying about being
perfect hang on let me read okay show
null alright we'll get him up there we
got this
get him up rawhide oh there we go
Jesus okay I got you go get it oh my god
that's a little vest floppy alright
[Laughter]
we're gonna
[Music]
I was gonna try and grab lower so we
could maybe reach the other side but
what fine we could still grab the handle
but you so okay okay we got it you want
me to ground in platform go go okay
right
oh that's great you fast there's no
hoops McGee I don't think that's why
they call me oops
McGee sounds like it must be true
all right what are we doing sup gamers
wait okay okay we have her so we have
each other all right okay no figure
yourself that's not it that's your face
and my face that's your face okay okay
subway come home there we go sequence
okay hmm
whoa all right my left hand I can grab
the coin wingait I'll grab I grab the
platform okay
oh hell yeah bring you around Oh God
okay this is a weird one where are we
supposed to know where oh mama
okay we just sailing huh all right I'll
be in the middle now okay let me get it
better yeah okay mark I think your left
hand should be the coin hand all right
you got it I got it like a freaking
champion Oh freaking out Rick wait can
we I
I didn't prep you yeah well warning
would have been nice
no hang on hang on everyone just chill
out okay take a breath I think what we
want to do is not launch but try and
extend me and I'll grab it right I think
that's the stretch yeah that's the one
so should I grab the very end of the
rope ooh maybe we if we get all the way
at the tippy tip okay good all right we
want to try it yeah yeah I don't know
what you think you're gonna be able to
grab cuz I'm not even know we're gonna
have to launch okay I can hit it from
the underside you you would've got
scared I'm not just gone for it right
you right you right you right you're
right you're right he's just thrust you
in like a needle being scared is exactly
what you want for me in that setting cuz
when I'm scared I go for the hole well
everyone just grab each other then
that's fine have we been doing this
entire game Oh doc yourself bring it in
okay so my right hand is free but it's
like I'm like oh my god stuck in my ear
okay I'm gonna go of it just bring it
right in there bring it right in let's
let's set it let's settle
I don't like you're just gonna go grab
oh we are stuck to each other why not
sure
I can't even exit this abomination I'm
stuck just let us go no no no we don't
need why do what do we need to die we
could just go on the floor no we're fine
that's it that's it everyone it's fine
no we're not I am absolutely not going
in the hall I'm hiding right here and
you can make marks me and marks arms are
intertwined in the beginning out it's
fine see I'm out I'm practically out I
have an idea I will see you mark you
want to grab it bring it in I will drop
it and just wrap just grab a while grab
it
there we go we're good all right bring
it in bring it in what a professional
this guy oh he goes all the way around
all yeah I'm gonna grab it and bring it
in yeah you are you sure are you sure oh
I died right on the edge of the hooks
okay Bob grab my hand you're gonna grab
it and you're gonna Bob your little
Topsy Turvey there but hang on let me
just let me just let me spike me on the
platform dedi gonna grab it and that was
cute that was cute my level I'm letting
go so I
okay you guys got each other I felt that
I oh ma I'm so close to getting I got it
there you got it you got it all right
now now I'm in charge of this atrocity
it's okay I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do
this I've got the top I got the top you
let go yeah let's try and slam let's
spike him on the deck there we go no now
we're not gonna smack you okay I was Mac
each other because if we're Mac's
extension we keep hitting the platform
of losing them in right you're right let
me think you trust me spin around you
try keep the rope we can do this let me
down oh [ __ ] we need to make a platform
it's fine here I come okay okay yeah I
have your other hand thank you thank you
who saved my life it was an epic swing
that was unbelievable I was pretty good
it was almost not believable at all
yeah oh jeez it was absolutely not even
fathomable okay
okay this train is right now this is a
solid this is unbelievably I got this I
got this
use the floaty goo you can do it remind
for myself floating goo yourself
okay going I am I'm gonna go save him I
sincerely doubt that myself out of this
bike so hard that I die permanently oh
okay I'm not gonna I don't want to harm
fun right didn't get the warning not
just coin we did not we got father's
friendship at the end of the day and we
got bragging rights oh wait hang on - I
got you it was I think we have to go get
out okay why am I in the middle of this
I didn't for this Bob let go of both
your hands the whole you trust me I'm so
boned right now
Bob's gonna be our grabber when we get
up there all right we can go all the way
what I'm gonna be the what we can go all
the way around no no all the way around
oh I've got it Oh get on top of it got
it okay okay I am tangled okay perfect
whoa
ah God grabbed it that was the wrong
button there you go easy okay oh okay
long gently release
easy peasy frenching intensifies we we
are one and the same right gamer see
around oh snap grab me oh my god I got
it I got it I got it
- grab this line okay okay okay just
along for this ride here oh I don't want
to be responsible for this swing public
oh alright okay you got this game right
now dude okay round oh you have the rope
all right yeah oh that's the wrong hand
okay there we go
I am I am letting go on the next swing
okay okay okay
whip it around we're fine we're fine
everybody calm down I am calm there hang
on hang on there we go what's doing
there but not so hard is it
I got this I got this okay if you need
us to swing what are we doing no no no
okay I'm not touching a huge Wow
oh okay you got me I've got everybody
okay okay
Bob go all right this is getting intense
am i calling in life with letting you go
fight them up in opportune time grab my
hand grab my hand
I've got no I'm coming to background I'm
gonna grab you there we go oh no are so
good gamers I almost let go of my right
the other way we're two wangled right
now okay I am the captain now
okay okay wanker Singh dangus are you
guys ready red shirt letting go of this
one this one yeah
push it get over there gamers help here
we go
wrong way wrong way wrong way okay we i
we I coin okay around oh wow I think
some blood came out on that one can we
get that coin is that possible I don't
know it's very far up there we'd have to
swing all right we're gonna have to all
right we're gonna have to be really
[Music]
tight all right do we I don't know if
like I'm helping as much as I feel I'm
helping with the movement I feel like
the middle person's wall is vital in
that only that the part of this moment
is like so important yeah
oh my god I don't know if I've ever made
all of those noises before yeah that's
fine for me I think that's I'm stressed
but that's a good girl that was amazing
that was really this is a marvel of
technology yet just happened
yeah that's amazing what you guys
watched at home is the first time
anyone's ever done that one of the first
times yeah boy what a game to test it
off pre-alpha test so I was hosting so I
feel like I'd have no idea how do you
feel like it worked there's no lag on
mind the only thing that was happening
was like a slight pixelation pressure
even Fetty landed but that's like yeah
that was all did you feel like right
interfered with your actual gameplay
very mono the gameplay was flawless on
that ya know that's so crazy
yeah of my grab shutting down we were
like saying one two three like oh yeah
true that's so crazy who's crazy [ __ ]
video games video games man time travel
okay take yourself which one are you I'm
the angry green ball at the end trying
to punch up room I'm the orange
douchebag throwing up the peace sign for
no reason I'm the yellow lady question
mark that's her she's making sassy sassy
Bob was making
[Music]
you